[Musique]
isabelle vous êtes là et isabelle
racontez nous ce que vous allez faire
je voulais comme je peux pas vous éviter
je vais l'éviter tout court ah oui
c'était donc d'aller faire ce jeu de
mots alors à expliquer donc donc savez
vous allez vraiment l'éviter je vais
voilà je vais d'abord me concentrer avec
chez moi c'est pas inné et puis après je
vais grimper grimper grimper comme un
masque au soleil en là le soleil ont
jusqu au soleil c'est une vraie lumière
vraiment et où on va voir les trucages
comme dans la piscine où on va c'est
vraiment fort non je vraiment je les vis
tu vraiment cela dit je n'ai qu'une
envie c'est que vous fassiez un coup de
pub comme vous avez fait un maximum de
partenaires
parce que si je prend quelque chose en
tête jusqu'à mach de sauter nos jours
les abonnés libe
allez-y c'est exceptionnel là mais
franchement j'ai vu les répète et ou
salariaux à tokyo s'est appréciée de
près du souci on aura des nouvelles de
tf1 dans un instant rare si on est de
retour sur la tour tf1
isabelle excusez moi ça dure longtemps
d'arriver là-bas mais non mais j'ai des
chaussures de dinde à l'enfant ciment
passer la manche en plastique c'est
fantastique ça mais vous avez vu ces
chaussures en pharmacie ou quoi c'est à
dire attendez attendez le cpie le tout
petit plus du tissage est juste regarder
regarde on va faire un petit point sur
tf1 les chéris bien avant qui avant
qu'ils n'interviennent regarder s'il
vous plaît point sur tf1 en régie merci
s'il vous plaît allez allez à brad hand
attendait isabelle attendu
[Musique]
toi
ça l'était de rien c'est ouf non cela
tous les gens qui passent ils étaient
six est dark ah non mais franchement
c'est complètement ouf c'est bon ils
sont sympas ah ben dis donc t'as pas le
choix ça vous auriez vous autre faille
s'attendre que la machine chauffe à
sancerre à mon avis ils doivent avoir 50
mais parce que les français n'ont alors
fait super pub pour alors plus le poids
pour le seul à sa fin la nuit vous
appartient la nuit ou demain
bon eh ben le dossier ben voilà isabelle
n'hésitez pas pourtant je n'ai pas posé
avec votre propre corps c'est un gâchis
et pudique des mots gentils on entend
encore des conneries ce toit à les
appelle c'est à vous même alors allez
mesa je me concentre excusez moi faites
nous rêver un bassin ya suffisamment ce
qu'il faut sur le plateau excusez moi du
peu
des plantations en direct
oui maxime pense à la panna cotta à ce
propos mon mari dit vous vous trompez
pas ce qu'elle appellerait que tu assez
mou ces camps de concentration ça
s'arrête une belle séquence nestlé qui
l'ont éloigné le tour est vite j'ai le
filet pour se concentrer là qu'on va
passer de la rc les scans de l'horreur
qui après un massage aux personnes en
tout cas le décor et doit
[Musique]
c'est faux
e
vous allez faire quoi là et
je gagne à m'intimider ton monte encore
touché le ferai
la bagasse tu jettes pour monter encore
à pas l'essayer
on va dire à la personne derrière le
paravent de remonter un peu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais allez-y tout seul soleil il et nous
reléguer le soleil ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est allé chercher la peau voilà je
vais lui faire la peau match mais sur
cette faille permet oui rien n'a rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]